you're gonna make mistakes you are going
to right
what writer do you know that doesn't
beat themself up what actor do you know
that doesn't beat themself
up right right like there's that
neurosis that's always like sitting on
your shoulder here you know that anxiety
is over here and just like oh my god
were they thinking about me like
dude give yourself a break relax
right because reality is most everyone
not even thinking about you that's true
they're thinking about themselves
and p.s they're having the same
conversation in your head that you are
and they're thinking you're thinking
that about them
right right we're all human beings right
give yourself a break you're doing the
best you can do
with what you have at that time and if
you are
obsessed as we say or you have that
burning desire whatever it may be
then just trust that you're going to
make mistakes but that's how you learn
mistakes are a great thing